so we've got the function f of x is
equal to x squared and what i'm
concerned with is finding the area under
the curve y is equal to f of x so that's
my y axis
this is
my my
x-axis and let me draw my function
my function looks like this at least in
the in the first quadrant that's where
i'll graph it for now i could also graph
it obviously in the second quadrant but
what i care about is the area under this
curve and above the positive x-axis
between
between x equals one
and x equals four
x equals four and i'm tired of
approximating areas i want to find the
exact area under this curve above the
x-axis
and the way we denote the exact area
under the curve this little brown shaded
area is using the definite integral the
definite integral from one to four
of f of x
dx
and the way that or the way i
conceptualize where this notation comes
from is we imagine a bunch of infinite
an infinite number of infinitely thin
rectangles that we sum up to find this
area and let me draw one of those
infinitely thin rectangles maybe not so
infinitely thin
so let me
draw it like this
so that would be one of the rectangles
that would be another rectangle this
should be reminiscent of a riemann sum
in fact that's where the riemann
integral comes from taking a riemann sum
where you have an infinite number of
these rectangles where the width of each
of the rectangles this is how i
conceptualize it is dx and the height of
this rectangle is the function evaluated
at an x that's within this interval
right over here and so
this part right over here is the area of
one of those rectangles and we're
summing them all up and this is kind of
an elongated s reminiscent of a sigma
for summing we're summing up the
infinite number of those infinitely thin
rectangle or the areas of those
infinitely thin rectangles between 1 and
4. so that's what the notation of the
definite integral comes from but we
still haven't done anything we've just
written some notation that says the
exact area of the
between 1 and 4 under the curve f of x
and above the x-axis in order to
actually do anything really productive
with this we have to turn to the second
fundamental theorem of calculus
sometimes called part two of the
fundamental theorem of calculus which
tells us that if f has an
anti-derivative
so if we have the antiderivative of f so
f of x is
derivative
derivative of some function capital f of
x or another way of saying it is f
capital f of x is the antiderivative
anti
derivative
of lowercase f of x then i can evaluate
this thing and we do a whole video on
conceptually understanding why this
makes sense we can evaluate this by
evaluating the antiderivative of f or an
antiderivative of f at 4
and from that
subtract the anti-derivative evaluated
at 1. so let's do it for this particular
case right over here
so we are taking i'll just rewrite this
statement instead of writing f of x i'll
write x squared
so the definite integral from 1 to 4 of
x squared
dx
well we're just going to have to figure
out what the antiderivative is so if f
of x
is equal to x squared what is capital f
of x equal to what is the antiderivative
well you might remember from your power
rules that if you take the derivative
with respect to x of
x to the third
you are going to get 3 x squared which
is pretty darn close to x squared except
for this factor of three so let's divide
both sides by three
let's divide both sides by three and you
get the derivative of x to the third
divided by three is indeed x squared or
you could say that this is the same
thing as the derivative with respect to
x of x to the third
over 3. take the derivative of this
it'll be 3 times 1 3 and then you'll
decrement the power will just be x
squared so this right over here once
again is x squared is just equal to
just equal to
x squared so in this case our capital f
of x our antiderivative is x to the
third
x to the third over three and so we just
have to evaluate that at four and at one
and sometimes the way we would with the
notation we'll use
is we'll say that the antiderivative is
x to the third
over three and we're going to evaluate
it the one i always like to just write
the numbers up here at four and from
that subtract it evaluated at one
sometimes you'll see people write a
little line here too where let's say
we're going to evaluate it at four and
then at one but i'll just do it without
the line so we're going to evaluate this
thing at four and from that subtracted
subtract it evaluated one so this is
going to be equal to
four to the third power is 64. so it's
going to be 64
over three let me color code it this is
this right over here is this right over
there and then from that we're going to
subtract this business evaluated 1.
well when you evaluate it at 1
you get 1 to the third is 1 over 3. you
get 1 3. so just to be clear
this
is this
right over there
and then we are ready to just subtract
these fractions 64 over 3 minus
1 3 is equal to 63
over 3
and 3 goes into 63 exactly exactly 21
times so whatever the units are the area
of this brown area is 21 square units